[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya tout juste quelques semaines nous
avons fêté les 30 ans du web
trente ans déjà pour une innovation qui
a profondément révolutionner bouleverser
notre manière de découvrir d'apprendre
de nous informer puis aussi de nous
distraire de commercer et évidemment de
nous connecter à cette occasion son
inventeur tim berners lee qui est devenu
d'ailleurs soeur tim berne adli
puisqu'il a été décoré par la reine
d'angleterre est fait chevalier a publié
une tribune et dans cette tribune
ils annoncent qu'ils voient des menaces
planaient sur son invention
ton premier de la liste des menaces
qu'il annonce se placent les cyber
attaques soutenues par les états la
cybercriminalité et le cyber harcèlement
par ailleurs dans une étude récente neuf
experts de la cybersécurité sur dix
pensent que nous sommes d'ores et déjà
en pleine cyberguerre 9 sur 10 quand on
parle de cybersécurité il faut savoir
que il y a deux phénomènes le premier
phénomène
c'est un phénomène individuel on a
l'impression quand on surf sur internet
parfois qu'on est dans une ville en
danger il faut circuler dans des
véhicules blindés qu'il faut construire
des miradors mettre des barbelés par
tous parce que à chaque coin de rue à
chaque instant on court le risque de se
faire rançonner
et donc il faut se méfier de tout et de
tous par ailleurs au niveau collectif
le world economic forum en 2019 dans la
liste des risques principaux qui
menacent l'économie a déclaré que le
quatrième risque qui menace l'économie
mondiale
ce sont le vol de données et le
cinquième les cyber attaques et ces
menaces arrive devant les migrations de
masse et devant la guerre de l'eau
alors on peut se poser la question et
pour faire un parallèle avec le monde de
l'écologie dans quel état allons-nous
naissait notre planète dans quel état
sera le monde demain et ce parallèle sur
l'internet
c'est dans quel état et l'internet
aujourd'hui et dans quel état sera
l'internet que nous laisserons à nos
enfants
vous avez sûrement entendu parler aussi
de menaces globales et de virus globo je
vais citer de noms qui circulent sur
l'internet depuis deux ans maintenant
wang cry et note médias qui sont ce
qu'on appelle des ransomware des
logiciels virus qui chiffre les données
des ordinateurs ou des serveurs et
ensuite demandent une rançon aux
propriétaires de ces ordinateurs pour
libérer la donne et qui a été chiffré
ces attaques ont non seulement ruiné des
entreprises elles ont aussi forcé des
sociétés à fermer des usines ça a été le
cas de renault ça a été le cas de saint
gobain et récemment d'une société
producteur d'aluminium en norvège ces
attaques ont mis à mal des pans entiers
de l'économie de certains pays à
commencer par le monde de la santé
en grande bretagne les hôpitaux anglais
qui ont été rançonné est inopérant
pendant quelques semaines
donc on a une menace aujourd'hui qui est
sérieuse et qui s'explique en
particulier par quatre phénomènes
le premier phénomène c'est évidemment la
nature humaine
il y aura toujours des gens malveillants
qui cherche on a abusé d'autres
personnes à les rançonner le deuxième
élément c'est un jeu du chat et de la
souris qui sont certes mignon mais qui
dans le domaine de la cybersécurité de
la cyberdéfense sont beaucoup moins on a
d'un côté les défenseurs qui en
permanence cherche à imaginer des
solutions de nouvelles formes de
protection et de l'autre côté des
attaquants qui vont adapter leur
tactique leur stratégie pour pénétrer
les réseaux ou les ordinateurs
développer de nouveaux rançon j ciel ou
nouveau virus et arriver à leurs fins et
ce ping-pong dure depuis des années
ça fait plus de vingt ans que les
premiers virus ont été inventés
et la tendance très clairement est en
train de s'aggraver
l'autre phénomène dans la cybersécurité
c'est que le monde se digitalise et tout
pages de code toute nouvelle application
est susceptible de contenir des erreurs
humaines des erreurs de programmation
des faiblesses ou des failles qui seront
ensuite utilisées exploité par les
attaquants pour arriver à leur fin et on
en arrive à avoir des brosses à dents
connecter des voitures évidemment
connecter des balance connectée et donc
l'informatique et le code informatique
rentrer dans l'adn de notre société et
ce code informatique
il n'est pas invulnérable il détient
souvent des failles qui sont utilisés
par les attaquants un nouvel aspect de
la logique de cette cyberguerre
c'est le côté asymétrique de la menace
on a d'un côté des défenseurs qui par
exemple pour une grande entreprise
doivent dépenser des centaines de
millions pour protéger tous les aspects
de leur système tous les aspects de leur
réseau les postes de travail les
utilisateurs nomades les serveurs les
cloud externe et de l'autre côté des
attaquants qui pour quelques dizaines
centaines de milliers d'euros peuvent
trouver un point faible un seul point
fait dans la cuirasse ou en l'occurrence
dans la citadelle de vauban pour arriver
à leurs fins et pénétrer le réseau de
l'entreprise donc on a une menace
asymétrique qui fait que la dynamique
dans le domaine de la cybersécurité
depuis des années va en s'aggravant et
que la situation devient de plus en plus
critique et que les alertes sont lancés
par tout un tas de personnes et
d'experts y compris le fondateur du web
pour nous alerter
alors je dresse aujourd'hui un pro
panorama très sombre assez angoissant
est-ce qu effectivement naviguer sur
l'internet de demain va devenir
impossible commercer va devenir
impossible
on a cette dynamique malsaine entre la
défense et l'attaqué
on a le sentiment parfois que l'attak
prend le dessus et heureusement depuis
environ trois ans un nouvel espoir
apparaît et cet espoir c'est
l'intelligence artificielle alors
l'intelligence artificielle en quelques
mots ou un exemple concret c'est la
capacité des ordinateurs des machines et
des systèmes à reproduire
comportements humains en particulier en
ce qui concerne l'apprentissage la
logique et la capacité de reconnaissance
et donc en matière informatique
un programme très simple sera capable de
savoir que tous les jours vous vous
connecter depuis un poste de travail sur
un réseau à toulouse et qu' il faudrait
vous alerter si le système détecte que
cet ordinateur
cet utilisateur que vous êtes se
connectent depuis paris à prendre plus
sophistiqués alimenté par par exemple
votre calendrier
vos réservations de voyages vos
réservations d'hôtels pour à savoir que
le vendredi vous êtes parfois à paris et
donc éviter de vous envoyer une alerte
lorsque vous vous connectez que paris et
quand vous augmentez la dimension de
l'équation avec des centaines des
millions de personnes évidemment des
centaines des milliers de bases de
données qui alimente il faut une
puissance de calcul
il faut une intelligence artificielle
pour être capable de traiter ces données
et à prendre petit à petit de vos
comportements pour ne pas vous envoyer
des alertes quand la situation est
normale et au contraire pour vous
alerter
quand la situation est exceptionnelle
alors l'intelligence artificielle elle a
besoin de trois choses principales pour
exister
la première chose c'est une grande
puissance de calcul
le deuxième élément c'est évidemment des
programmes informatiques des algorithmes
comme souvent les appels de plus en plus
sophistiquées qui vont traiter la donner
et utiliser le maximum de la puissance
de calcul des machines à leur
disposition et le troisième élément dans
cette intelligence artificielle
c'est le volume de données qui vont
alimenter ces systèmes donc on entend
très souvent parlé de la donne et c'est
à nous de nouveaux pétroles la nouvelle
énergie et pourquoi parce que
l'intelligence artificielle le
traitement de masse des données a besoin
d'un grand volume de données
or quand on est du côté de la
cyberdéfense
on a un avantage très important qui est
justement un accès un volume de données
phénoménal on peut savoir quels sont les
systèmes les machines les ordinateurs
sur un système d'information
on peut connaître les utilisateurs leurs
idées
c'était numérique leur comportement on
peut placer des sondes sur le réseau
pour récupérer le flux du réseau et
analyser ce flux on peut avoir des
sources d'information externes sur les
menaces en temps réel
on peut et sait et c'est donc le volume
de données qui est possible de traiter
quand on est du côté de la cyberdéfense
est extraordinairement important il
explose en ce moment parallèlement on a
une situation où la ressource humaine
les expertises disponibles est un
problème l'année prochaine en 2020 il y
aura au niveau global plus de 1.5
millions de positions non occupés dans
le domaine de la cybersécurité donc si
vous êtes motivés pour changer de
carrière ou trouver un job la
cybersécurité porteuse un million cinq
par manque de compétences par manque
d'expertisé par manque de personnel
formé sur le marché et quand on a cette
équation beaucoup de données à traiter
et peu de ressources humaines c'est
clairement l'opportunité idéale pour
l'intelligence artificielle de briller
et d'ailleurs depuis environ trois ans
100 % des start-up que je vois pour des
partenariats pour des conseils pour des
investissements ont dans leur approche
technologique
incorporer des éléments de machine
learning d'intelligence artificielle
d'automatisation parce que ça devient
fondamentalement nécessaires à la survie
et à la victoire de la cyberdéfense
on a aussi depuis quelques années et
c'était d'ailleurs en 2016 des centres
de recherches qui ont commencé à
développer des systèmes autonomes le 1er
la première démonstration c'était en
2016 dans un événement qui s'appelait le
cyber grand challenge organisé par l'
agence de l'innovation pour la défense
et la sécurité américaine
pendant ce challenge des machines il y
avait huit finalistes s'affrontaient
pour démontrer la capacité d'un système
totalement autonome à trouver des
failles dans des logiciels à bloquer les
attaques sur ses logiciels et à corriger
ses failles
mais évidemment comme le symbolise cet
ep c'est une arme à double tranchant
l'intelligence artificielle utilisé du
côté de la cyberdéfense quasiment
maintenant systématiquement
dans les approches technologiques des
start up et des sociétés qui se
développe et qui innove mais aussi
évidemment du côté des attaquants
il ya beaucoup d'exemples je vous en
donnerai deux le premier c'est un
journaliste anglais qui s'appelait
andrew mcgill qui a fait une petite
expérience l'année dernière il a posté
sur internet un logiciel domotique de
façon non protégés et sans en faire la
publicité
ce logiciel il a reporté plusieurs fois
il s'est aperçu qu'il suffisait d'une
dizaine de minutes pour qu'il soit
détectée est attaqué par des robots
informatiques qui automatiquement aller
chercher des vulnérabilités dans le code
et le mettre à mal
dix minutes c'est impossible que ce soit
fait par des humains il ya déjà du côté
de l' attaque d automatisation des
systèmes qui vont automatiquement
attaquer les logiciels non protégés même
si ceux ci ne sont pas médiatisés et
public
le phénomène est aussi intéressant parce
que aujourd'hui plus de la moitié du
trafic sur internet est générée par des
machines c'est du trafic qui n'est pas
humain on a dépassé les 50% très
récemment parce que les objets connectés
se multiplient parce que il ya ce qu'on
appelle des crawler qui vont chercher
des informations sur l'internet et 15%
environ de ce trafic automatique et
considérés comme malveillants donc la
proportion du trafic malveillant sur
internet est en croissance permanente et
démontre aussi que les cybercriminels
les cyberattaques en utilise
l'automatisation et le machine learning
et l'intelligence artificielle pour
mettre à mal le système
un deuxième exemple lui aussi qui date
de 2017
c'est un logiciel de conversation
automatique que microsoft avait lancé
qui s'appelait taille thinking about you
guys l'acronyme de thinking about you
qui était censé converser avec des
adolescents sont une cible 19 25 ans
pour de façon automatique interagir et
apprendre de cette interaction et ça
nous avait écrit il ya très longtemps
que l'art de la guerre est basé sur la
duperie et l'exemple de taille est
intéressant parce que microsoft a été
forcé de débrancher de désactiver ce
robot et l'expérience
moins de 16 heures parce qu'un groupe
d'activistes avait commencé à alimenter
les conversations et à polluer
l'intelligence artificielle de ce
système jusqu'à le rendre raciste
violent et donc forcer microsoft à le
débrancher donc là on a une autre
tactique de la part des attaquants qui
est la pollution des données qui
nourrissent l'intelligence artificielle
qui nourrissent la capacité de
l'intelligence artificielle à apprendre
et donc à progresser la duperie fait
partie de la cyberguerre elle fait
évidemment partie de la guerre de façon
générale alors on est vraiment
aujourd'hui dans une logique de course
aux armements et tout le monde a en tête
l'exemple de l'urss qui s'est effondrée
parce que les états unis ont mis plus
d'argent sur la table ont lancé des
efforts de guerre des étoiles et cetera
qui ont mis à mal la capacité de l'urss
avant un modèle pérenne et assure
investir dans la sécurité par rapport
aux besoins économiques généraux dans la
cyber sécurité
c'est la même chose je suis convaincu
qu'il va falloir mettre des ressources
en commun des ressources d'entreprise
des ressources d'état d'ailleurs en
novembre l'année dernière a lieu à paris
à l'unesco dans le cadre du forum de
gouvernance de l'internet un appel
l'appel de paris pour la confiance et la
sécurité dans le cyberespace
cet appel il a été signé par 65 et à des
centaines d' agences gouvernementales
plus 300 en l'occurrence et des
centaines et des centaines d'entreprises
donc on a d'ores et déjà une
mobilisation des états des agences
gouvernementales et des entreprises pour
mettre en commun des ressources ont en
tout cas avoir des intentions de mettre
en commun des ressources et trouver un
cadre à la cyberguerre
mais comme on l'a vu aussi dans le
domaine du climat et d'allumer pour
contre le réchauffement climatique les
efforts au niveau des états les
déclarations de bonnes intentions ne
suffisent pas et je suis persuadé que
seule une mobilisation individuelle de
tous les internautes du collectif
vva mettant la pression sur les états
permettre effectivement à terme de
potentiellement forcer les états les
gouvernements et les entreprises à
mettre en commun des ressources pour que
ces ressources soient largement
supérieures à celles qui peuvent être du
côté de l' attaque et donc de finalement
mettre fin à la cyberguerre est donc ce
n'est peut-être pas l'intelligence
artificielle seul qui mettra fin à la
cyberguerre
mais très clairement l'intelligence
collective
[Applaudissements]